tomorrow a group of locals from Hope
Christian Health Center will be
assisting those facing homelessness in
the valley by washing their feet this
will be their second time doing this
event and the center CEO says it has
multiple purposes one being to reach
those who don't have access to health
care in fact certain medical conditions
like diabetes can actually be spotted by
examining one's feet these pictures are
from the first event which was
Thanksgiving weekend where over 150
people were serviced they say the other
Factor relates to their faith the act of
washing feet carries symbolic meanings
in the CEO Steve Flores says it's meant
to show they are here to serve the
community that event is happening at 314
foremaster Lane across the street from
Catholic Charities of Southern Nevada
more information can be found on our
website